tonight it is clear the bite
administration is unwilling to stand up
to
the world's hostile regimes and hostile
actors the administration is defending
their decision to lift sanctions
on and this i find amazing on a russia
pipeline
give vladimir putin give him the waiver
so he can continue building his pipeline
to supply energy
to our allies after he killed the
high-paying career jobs and energy
independence that our energy was giving
us here at home
in fact joe is honoring putin by
granting him a one-on-one meeting next
month
maybe putin can challenge him to another
debate and wish that he feels
better pretty insulting i'm sure that's
going to go so great for joe i wonder if
they're going to get lectured like the
chinese lectured joe biden
and his administration in anchorage now
meanwhile joe biden won't even stand up
for basic american values here at home
conservatives they're now fighting back
steve miller's america first legal
they want a temporary restraining order
for a restaurant owner
who says biden's coveted relief plan is
discriminatory
for prioritizing minorities for relief
funds
and the same group has filed a proposed
class action on behalf
of restaurants in texas and pennsylvania
who say the covert relief law
discriminates against them because of
their race here with the reaction
the author of the upcoming book do what
you said you do
fighting for freedom in the washington
swamp ohio congressman jim jordan
who should be running for senate but he
won't listen to me and former white
house chief of staff mark meadows
uh we'll get to you in a second but but
mark meadows
this this legal group with stephen
miller that's your group
well it is stephen's doing a great job
and and it's not surprising that the
left is already saying he's the worst
individual
in america because he's actually taking
it to them and holding the biden
administration accountable
but somebody needs to hold him
accountable because he is missing in
action
and joe biden in his leadership style
is mr appeasement uh across the board
last night i i mentioned that i guess
the reagan library
peggy noona's host is hosting some event
uh
a time for choosing for the republican
party jim jordan
well i don't know i haven't changed my
agenda it's the make america great
agenda it's the america first agenda
that's the agenda that worked so well
for
for donald trump in his first three
years prior to the pandemic
i believe would work again uh what what
does peggy need to choose
what she wants to eliminate any and all
conservatives from the party is that
what they're choosing
no and it's also an american strength
agenda so that we project strength
around the world not this weakness that
our enemies see
you've talked about what took place in
anchorage two months ago
where the treatment that secretary
blinken received from his chinese
counterpart
that would never happen to mike pompeo
in a trump administration
and then you put everything with it sean
the the how the lack of respect from our
adversaries coupled with the crisis on
the border
with inflation sean every lumbers up
aluminum's up steels up the price of gas
the price of eggs the price of milk the
prices
everything you can think of the price is
up americans sense that
and then they also see just the chaos
surrounding biden and they also
understand
that their taxes are going to go up and
more spending is coming
that's what they're that's what they
fear so let's get back to america first
and projecting strength to round the
world to our adversaries well i i've
been saying it every night i won't
repeat
the list it only takes me a minute mark
meadows it's not that complicated
because it's also everything i believe
for
33 years in radio and have expressed
and tried to articulate but why is there
any debate whatsoever
because it seems like the establishment
rhinos
um that let's see didn't have a plan to
actually repeal or replace obamacare
which i know you know very
intimately all the details of
they weren't ready for donald trump to
go along with him when the moment came
when
it wasn't a show vote anymore
well listen they're talking about it's a
time for choosing the american people
have already chosen and and they showed
up in
unbelievable volumes that said what we
want is a president who will keep
america first
joe biden is america last we don't have
to look any further than the
cancellation of the keystone pipeline
and then what do they do for russia they
take off the sanctions so that they can
finish
their pipeline we see not uh not uh
surprisingly today that the palestinians
actually referred to secretary blinken
as secretary clinton well that's because
they're reverting back
to a clinton way of doing business and
what do they get what did
what did the bible administration do two
thousand rockets into israel
and what did they get in return they get
all kinds of concessions from the biden
administration that's not leadership
it's time that we can revert back to
what works and that is peace through
strength
a boldness that president donald trump
brought to the american people
okay jim jordan is donald both of you
are close to the
former president is donald trump running
for president jim jordan we give it to
you first
yeah i think he is i every time i speak
to him
he says that he wants to run he plans to
run i think but he hasn't fully
committed that yet but i certainly hope
he does because
no president has done more of what he
said he would do
than president trump best president i
think we've ever had keeping his word
doing what he said
doing what he was elected to do that's
the kind of individual we need in the
white house and that's the kind of
individual that our adversaries
respected
because they knew he was putting
america's interests first and standing
strong for the principles that matter
last word mark thanos yeah listen sean
when he came down that escalator the
left has been going after him attack
after attack after attack
from russia hoax to impeachment now
we're even still seeing it in new york
city
here's what i will say is the american
people want him to run
i believe he'll run and at the end of
the day it's a time for choosing and the
american people will choose donald trump
and really all he needs to do right now
is just enjoy life
recharge the batteries play golf because
joe biden is doing everything that you'd
ever want
to ruin the country in the meantime so
there's nothing he can do until
he or somebody gets back in power and
implements that agenda
uh by the way and jim jordan should run
for senate with his new book
just saying hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else